[Music]
and we are white
and let's go e4 and
um c5 so
let's well we can go for an open
sicilian we can go main line
uh but let's do a smith more we got to
do a smith mora
that is the og line for people
who want something very tactical
four nine seven four men
thank you guys all right so c3
smith mora lovely opening
i'm not baiting anybody yeah so he takes
it nice accepted smith mora
okay now i will preface this by saying
i'm not a smithmore expert i actually
don't know it
virtually at all but i would imagine
that it involves developing your pieces
actively
so basically these pieces go here
and well let's continue developing
knight f3 i think is the move
and then bishop c4
yeah so we're just developing
and
you disconnect he's having okay e6 is
correct
okay so i'm already out of book okay i'm
already out of book but
you know this guy is playing playing
very well
all right so
again we shouldn't i think really modify
our strategy too much we should complete
our development and to do that
we have to castle first right we
castling
allows you to pay more attention to
attacking because if your king is in the
center that's
always in the back of your mind thank
you silent spaz 91
i think i went wrong here somewhere i
mean this isn't he's not supposed to be
able to get the bishop here i think
knight f3 is actually a mistake
i think you're supposed to start with
bishop c4 for that reason but it's okay
we'll we'll we'll make something of this
okay knight f6 which i think gives us a
good try
now the gamut mentality dictates
that you know that the statute of
limitations on exploiting
uh the compensation is limited if he
goes bishop e7 and castles we're going
to run out of compensation
so the move comes very naturally here
and
there's some calculation involved we're
going to play it quickly thank you
colorado
and oh correct both of you for the prime
these subs are awesome
okay e5
okay uh now you might look at this and
say wait a second
d takes e5 and then we either have to
trade queens which is bad for us because
we've sacrificed upon
or we just have to give up two pawns
um but he doesn't do it unfortunately
which doesn't allow me to explain
why this was would have been good for
white so i'm gonna write this down
thank you uh nauseous maxime
all right so knight h5 there's a lot of
stuff that's wrong with this move
right it's just it puts the knight on
the side and he's basically
giving us what we want and i think
there's a very simple move we think
about if we look at the knight on h5
okay guys
seriously it's funny but let's let's
focus on the game okay
i'm putting a lot of effort to decide
you know i'm all for
having fun but i also want to want to
stay on track so h3a
h3 is very strong because it attacks the
bishop bishop has nowhere to go
he takes on f3 we take back and we fork
everything
he goes to f5 we have another very
elementary fork with g4
and this is basically just losing queen
takes f3 just look at this i mean
knight is hanging pawn is hanging he
maybe stays ali ah no d5 doesn't say
what happens if d5 what do we and i
think he's gonna do it
what do we do if he plays d5 there we go
we have a very tactical move here if you
guys wanted but this should be
the simple move is bishop b5 check but
if we want to be
insane what should we do what is the
insane move
and the reality is it's not insane at
all it's winning
so check of course wins the night but
let's go 965
gamma mentality where queen is out his
king is in the center he's not developed
his knight is also hanging so it's very
low stakes right
worst comes to worst look at how many
threats there are
it's quite simple
well i'd respectfully disagree with
starking the thing is i don't like
banning people
for any reason particularly when they're
just innocently trying to make a joke
but
you know sub only is a way to sort of
calm everyone down a little bit
queen takes f7
checkmate made to his majesty okay
so again pretty straightforward game
smith mora gambit now if you're if
you're black
and you want to avoid the sort of the
craziness the knight f6 is a very
good move here this forces the
transition into the alpine after e5
knight d5 which the alapan we've played
in the five minute speedo of course
but anyways he takes and yeah i think
that f3
is is wrong or i went wrong somewhere
bishop g4 maybe somebody can tell me
what am i hallucinating here yeah i
think this is the move
thank you josh waxio for the tier one
i think bishop c4 is the move to
disallow the bishop from coming out to
g4
all right so knight f3 bishop g4 anyway
we go bishop c4
now if he goes knight c6 here we have a
very typical tactic we can take on f7
and knight g5 and win the bishop so
that's just something to bear in mind
thank you uh the tap potato so he did
everything right until knight f6
he should have started with knight c6
and i think black is doing great here
but um let's understand why this is good
after d takes c5 the
the thing that everybody has to realize
is that fact that the queens are off the
board does not mean
we don't have attacking chances we not
only have attacking chances we have a
big attack
we're first of all attacking f7 he's got
to drop his bishop back
we can't give a check here well we can
maybe but
we can just get our bishop out and
everybody should see how much trouble
black is and despite the fact that the
queens are gone
rooks on c1 and d1 other knight can come
to b5
this is super nasty so
the rule is that you don't want to
automatically rule out an option
that trades queens when you are down
material the queen trade does not
it lessens the probability of a strong
attack but it certainly doesn't
uh doesn't make it impossible okay
so can you play g4 um
you can but then maybe knight takes g4
black is holding on here
because the bishop is simultaneously
defending everything here
anyways after knight h5 h3 it's all
basically all over bishop f5 g4
and again here we have two pieces
hanging so we need to consider well what
if
one of them moves with check that would
be this move pick up a knight
but this is even better i think because
i mean just look at the amount of
threats that we have you don't need to
calculate anything here
boom boom and boom and boom and the game
is over
okay now bruja sucks lono sucks
this entire community is horrible
basically does d5 after e5 do anything
at all
asks malcolm tucker good question d5 is
not a dumb move at all not a dumb move
at all
because it counter attacks the bishop
and if we give a check on b5
and this is where you have to be very
careful this looks like it wins a piece
but it doesn't
because this very same knight that is
hanging can move back and block the
check and black is good thank you sorry
barry
but i think we can take here we can
basically do the same thing that we
would have done otherwise we can take
the queen and go 95
this pawn just adds to the heat you know
then we can get our bishop to g5 and set
up a discovery
so this is quite similar but it's a
great question and
these are the kinds of moves that you
should consider
okay um any questions right exactly mr
nwa
all right guys looks like we're all
clear and the time
has come from me to call it a night
oh my god or not holy smokes 25 from
proffer
my lands girl damn girl
25 from proffer to put us
back over 5 000. i mean
that's just insane and i i don't think
proper realizes i'm actually
sitting on the chair oh my lands
captain cola with 10 holy
mama what is going on here chess jacob
with a 13 months
that definitely deserves another game
that's definitely
worthy of one more
well and again every time i try to leave
you know this just represents how toxic
the community is you're paying me to
leave well
you failed because i'm staying for one
more but only one more
so don't get any don't get any ideas
thank you rcy 10 for the prime
okay um one last one
game three
thanks guys appreciate it wrapper
appreciate it captain cola
and everybody else okay
okufa so d4
all right to spam red whoa three subs
from red red sweater and this ice spam
so
we're gonna play it very traditionally
we're gonna play a queen's gamba
declined
which is the og solid okay plays g3 he
doesn't go for the queen's gamut
i can't keep up with this vibrant fc
thing for the prime
now g3 is a move it's not particularly
dangerous and
you know if you play the queen's gamut
declined there's a temptation to play e6
in this position much as you would
but the the issue with g3 is because he
doesn't immediately challenge our center
he allows us much like in the karaoke by
the way
to bring the bishop to f5 and only now
to play e6
right our bishop is outside the punch
and this is like an ideal setup
basically this is a london setup now
what moves
are are uh played in a london setup well
often we go
h6 to give the bishop a little bit of
luft on
on h7 so let's go h6 now let's
make sure that moves like knight h4 are
going to be rendered innocuous
and knight c3 as we've discussed is a
classic inaccuracy at this level because
he's blocking the c
pawn from coming to c4 now our center is
going to be
super like as solid as it gets in fact
we can go c5 if we want to
but i don't see the russian doing that
let's complete our development bishop d6
is fine
bishop b7 so let's go bishop b7 maybe
bishop d6 he would have gotten ip5 and
now it's castle
he's not threatening e4 because we've
defended it three times
he's only attacking it twice
and now i think we're ready to play c5
if he gives us the opportunity
and h4 okay well that's exactly why we
played h6
okay so what he's doing is actually a
legitimate idea
i'm quite kind of impressed but
in this position it's not going to serve
him too well i think he's going e4 he's
opening up the center
now we have a couple of ways to meet
this we can
well we can take on e4
um let me think actually
this is actually not so simple
well because there's there's many
appealing options for black
now the simplest is to take everything
on e4 and you'll notice that he'll be
missing
a fiance bishop so his king becomes a
little weak
but i also noticed that this is a
liability like the idea bishop takes h4
has to be considered
so what clever sequence do we have here
using the fact that this knight is
potentially vulnerable to capture which
would ruin his pawn structure
conceivably night knight takes the
forest start
now there's issues with this now we take
intermediate
h4 currently we're up a pawn right
if he's very clever he'll go knight c5
here but he takes
now we take we've ruined his pawn
structure
and depending on what he does if bishop
takes c4
we've got other cool ideas there
yeah unfortunately we can't take here
because i think he takes on b7
and wins our exchange although that's
still
something to consider maybe a sack but
that's not the way that we play with
black
we play super meat and potatoes but
we also don't have to take on e4 and the
issue with taking on e4 is that he gets
a rook on e4 which could lift to g4
you guys should be able to see that
that's a little unpleasant so
he's not really threatening to take our
bishop you know just take with the king
that's fine
so what move would be the sort of the
zen approach here
well b6 blunder's the rook right b6 he
takes the knight c6
he takes the knight great you know for
the small price of double puns we get
opposite colored bishop
which in the middle game favors the
attacker he takes the bishop correct
he'll probably give us a check here
but we actually are forking two of his
pawns which is funny but
true stricken off the record
well c6 would do the same thing but we
actually also develop a piece right
so we're doing the same thing that c6
says except we are also developing
all right and i'm going to reward myself
with the cracker
okay rookie four is great this guy is
good
but now it's time to make things go boom
we have a small window of opportunity
his bishop is not yet developed which
means that he's under re he's on demand
on the king side
so if we can just pry things open if we
can get things
flowing if we can open the center which
means if we can take this pawn
at any cost then he's going to pay the
price for this and so
e5 is possible but f5 is more forcing
e5 he could have played d5 kept the
center closed
although that's still good after knight
d4 but f5
forces his rook to move if it goes to f4
then we go e5
and we win and if he takes on e6 we play
knight takes d4 hitting the rook
discover to
check ideas and that seems very nasty
yeah i'll so after this game before i
leave i'll i'll read the reddit thread
and then i'll address it and then i'll
go
boom goes the dynamite that's right
so rook f4 e5 is good because it attacks
the rope right
and he can't take the pawn because his
queen is his queen is undefended
okay his queen everybody should see this
that's exactly why we need to act with
urgency
because the moment he gets his bishop
out the queen is no longer undefend and
we no longer have this kind of tactics
we don't have a discovered attack or
discovered check because the queen can
take the knight
but it's okay we're going to take on h4
we're just gonna do some reddit react
chat we're just gonna write it reacts
okay but yeah we're done after this game
all right let's snag snag this fun
so my match tomorrow is at six eastern
six p.m eastern
it's going to be broadcast live on
chess.com like twitch twitch.tv slash
chess there's going to be an official
commentary
and i'm playing eric yeah okay
rogue g3 all right
well it's a good move for sure
so we don't really have to do anything
fancy here one idea
would be to bring this guy into the game
and create an x-ray against this queen
yeah f4 um he would have taken our
knight and simultaneously pinned the
queen
i consider that move but it doesn't work
all right
yeah this is bad for white of course but
yeah ludwig is insane now what are we
actually threatening here is a good
well we're not again careful about these
checks because both of them the queen
can take but what are we actually
threatening here
we are threatening something and we can
play this something here i believe
so first of all yeah f4 is possible
already
but i'm talking specifically about this
discovery do we yeah knight b3 knight b3
attacks the rook in the corner
so f4 rook g4 might be a little bit
iffy now f4 he'll go rook g4 and attack
the queen
so i don't see a compelling reason not
to play knight p3
yeah now
with such a thing you have to be very
careful if you look at this g7
pawn this would be a thing you should
identify and say well if his queen can
get to a square word attacks g7
that'll be a mate thread but he can't if
you look carefully
nowhere he can't go anywhere with his
queen that threatens me
okay queen f3 just double checking
there's
no shenanigans yeah we can take the rook
and it's over you know we we have to be
a little careful here our king is
a bit weak but other than that it's just
winning
yeah queen takes b7 yeah let's get down
to business here
we can throw in a check then this knight
now this pawn is controlling the seventh
ring so we can take on c2 and swing the
knight around to e1
with devastating effect we can also
swing the queen e4 there's a lot of
possibilities here
let's go 91 check thank you shasta
okay check now who sees the follow-up
what's the follow-up here it looks like
we may have screwed up because our two
pieces are hanging
but i've seen this if you have good
tactical vision
you'll see that there's checkmate and a
couple of moves nope not queen c4 that
one is the queen
it starts with the rookie one if he
takes the knight we have queen e4
checkmate
you can stay yeah yeah okay
nice and how do you find this you just
solve puzzles and stuff like that's just
not
there's no secret formula it's just what
it is
all right um honestly i'm a little whoa
shasta with five thank you shasta
i have worth and wildish klambin zero
with a prime
tons of subs no i'm i'm gonna go
uh so that was a simple game i think
this the only interesting moment was
this knight takes e4 on bishop h4
i'll just point very quickly out
that had he i think the correct approach
here for white would have been
knight c5 because that counter attacks
b7
and it's a double-edged position here
but i kind of relied on him to miss it
and he did
so in in a classical game i would have
done something perhaps a little bit
different but
this setup with knight on c3 is risky
because if white doesn't get e4
uh in then white's going to be out of a
plan and we on the other hand have this
lever
still available with c5 so his plane was
very
it was very reasonable but it didn't
work out and in this position
again we're attacking these two pawns if
he takes
then we're still attacking our bishop is
going to
contribute through the light squares
which he doesn't have any control over
which is what makes these positions so
difficult
okay very quickly um before i go
i know you guys want me to specifically
read out the reddit post
now this is not an attempt to put down
uh you know all of the criticism by by
no means in fact i'm acknowledging it
let me just find it i'll read it off to
you
so nerdiski speeders have been
misleading it reads
it reads i've been enjoying lately
watching narendra speedrun
and obviously it is great and i find it
very instructional
thank you however at the same time in my
humble opinion the way he plays is
misleading
yes there are a lot of instructional
moves and it is incredibly helpful but
he plays theory moves all the time
so he avoids getting in a bad position
from the start that's not representative
of the issues
player of 1200 to 1800 rating faces
while climbing
a 1500 player will not play theory
against a lot of openings
and therefore he she will get a bad
position for example when he encounters
the king's indian he plays theoretical
moves and obviously he gets amazing
positions
uh well i don't really play d4 so i
think he means when i play the king's
indian but a low rated player does not
have that kind of theoretical
information
that's why i think even though the
speedrun is really instructional and
good fun
at the same time does not reflect
appropriately the experience of an
improving player
so very well thought out points
so the one so the area where i think
you know there's a slightly false
assumption is in this
spot where he says that's
um a 1500 player will not play theory
against a lot of openings
there's no inherent reason that that
that you wouldn't play theory against a
lot of openings
and that's exactly my point right if you
put that work in to get good positions
in most games
you're going to boost your improvement
to the maximum even if you might at
first experience
if you're if you're sort of a player who
tries to avoid theory
and play the london system or something
and then you switch to the danish
there's going to be growing pains but
once you
pass them you're going to get rewarded
for it and
i agree that part of the experience of
climbing is playing bad positions and
screwing up and i don't do that
uh and i agree that that is a that is a
deficiency now that's something that i
don't cover as much
how to get out of bad positions i've
done it once or twice but
and it's something that i might
incorporate um
so yeah i i totally acknowledge that um
and that's something i i'll think about
for future lessons